this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday august the 8th i want to welcome
true classic the absolute best fitting
t-shirts for men
listen to me finding the right t-shirt
when you're a fat [__] like me is
frustrating most t-shirts are too tight
on your gut or look way too big get it
together [__] you gotta start
dressing like a gentleman true classic
gets you a better fit at an affordable
price
men's t-shirts are designed to look good
on skinny models they're not gonna work
for us guys true classic these taper off
at the bottom they fit tightly around
the chest and shoulders and they
highlight your best attributes listen if
you look at the joint today i got one of
my shirts on right now and it's smoking
it's comfortable
it's light for this hot weather that
we've been having and it fits
tremendously tip top magoo the shirts
this soft and smooth are usually
expensive the first thing you'll notice
how soft and smooth your true classic is
for boys for big boys they got long body
options and up the sizes for 3x it's
time to learn to dress like a gentleman
upgrade your wardrobe with true classic
i'm going to get you
25 off a true classic when you go to
truceclassic.com
code joey again that's 25 percent off
and free shipping for over a hundred
dollars with codejoey
trueclassic.com get yourself looking
like a doctor at true classic let's get
this party started it's monday
[__] morning and we got
tj englishness [__]
there you go tip top magoo
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 8th of august welcome to
uncle joey's joint today i'm
[Music]
my co-host today and my main man is my
brother i love him with all my heart
this guy inspires me he's a great author
mr t.j english what's happening brother
joey how you doing nice to be out here
in jersey yes nice down here in the
farmland yeah we can go get a pig after
this can breathe out here
and breathe out here you know wide open
isn't it
i thought i just came from my place in
downtown manhattan went through the
tunnel
come over here often the sky opens up
and you can breathe i felt like i'm in
the country it is i i
picked this area because my brother
lives in morganville
and i was in shock
he had a fish company he still does
he would leave his house at four go to
the fulton fish market
and then
we deliver fish till one
and we'd be in morganville by two
o'clock
he we go through his garage we take
showers because we stunk like fish
and then we jump in the pool and he put
the fish from the day on the grill while
we were swimming
and i'm like how can you be in the
world's best city
in one minute and then you're down the
[__] your mountains like this is
different it's not like going down the
shore it's nothing like that this is
farmland this is i'm next to colt's neck
and that's queen latifah that's bruce
springsteen that's a bunch of people but
when you drive in cold snake those
people have horses they got everything
you know what i found out i did not know
this and a lot of people aren't gonna
know this
new jersey's the state with the most
[__] horses
yeah
i had no [__] idea that there's more
horses here than [__] anywhere so
it's and i'm gonna tell you the truth
you want me to tell how i ended up here
let me tell you a weird story that only
and i've never told anybody this only
the tj i understand when i was a kid i
was a santoria kid and i was involved
and i used to go to all the
eatings and you know the chicken
killings and [__] do you know where they
got their animals from
my bro
because i remember still being a kid and
going you go to marlborough isn't that a
cigarette like it used to be a cigarette
you know right and then to add more to
this when i was about 13 i used to come
down here every weekend to
the english town
uh raceway
funny cars and then they have the
english town flea market
where it's everything stolen you know
from cd platform not cds in those days
from 8-track players to so i would come
down here on the weekends and buy
limousines for the feet julia serving
sneakers
they were like
five bucks and i would take them up
north and sell them for 21. yeah you
know so
it's like i have a connection to this
area in the weirdest way but the
santeria connection is just oh man if
you get us started on that again
remember when we're on rogan show i
still get people come up to me and say i
can't believe you had a
abacua
ceremony on the rogan show you know
because we got off on that but you know
that's what got me into latin music
latin jazz which i love really was by
way of
hearing it
through santeria ceremonies the drum
playing the chanting all that kind of
stuff
and when you hear that when they take
that element of afro-cuban music and
they feed it into american jazz that's
my sweet spot man that's the music i
love
is that like the chow and those guys
yeah yeah i have an album here that i
really love this is my all time like
people always say you know the
bella vista country club whatever yeah
this is a social club uh not for me i
like this [__] from the 60s that i have
[__] up
yeah
on base and the [__] taped it
apartment yeah
that's the best you ever hear of china
pozo [__] yeah jonapozo [__] yeah
[__] yeah the percussionist the konga
player he got murdered at the age of 33
by his marijuana dealer
wow he he
dizzy gillespie went down to havana cuba
and heard about him they told him
there's a conga player
in havana
that plays in the traditional santeria
style in fact he was a babalao
in uh uh uh a strain of the religion
called lakumi
yeah yeah
local yeah and so they so dizzy
gillespie went down there in the late
40s and got him and brought him to the
united states
and used him
in an orchestra that played at carnegie
hall
with charlie parker and
and a guy named chico farrell who was
cuban cuban irish who was one of the
founders of this music latin jazz
and they debuted at carnegie hall and
changed the course of american music and
shauna pozo was 32 years old at the time
and this guy was perched on the edge of
a mega career
and then he he got murdered by his uh
marijuana dealer in harlem one afternoon
great tragedy for now dizzy worked a lot
of cubans he did he really liked it uh
machito
uh mario bowser mario bowser is a very
important figure in the history of jazz
in general mario bowser came up here in
like the 30s and went to work in dizzy
gillespie's orchestra in the 30s and he
hit dizzy gillespie to cuban music and
that's when latin music started working
its way into jazz all the rhythms of of
afro-cuban music started to change the
direction of jazz and that [__] you
listen to that today it's as fresh as if
it was just created yesterday that's how
it sounds great yeah
it really does i didn't know
listen i love the afro-cuban thing yeah
it's something that you can't talk about
it really it's not like you meet your
friends on the corner
and go have you heard the last tattoo
it's something that i grew up listening
to and i really liked
i love santoria music and i still play
it in the mornings on mondays to salute
the saints and [__] i still play it
uh but the afro cuban
it's done like the iphone cuban whole
thing is
it's such a culture that i can't even
explain it like i'm stuttering because i
cannot it's done so much in so many ways
like those slaves going through cuba
built such i'm watching something on
netflix now about a 12 episode cuban
thing it's tough to watch at times but
it's slow you know it's [__] slow but
cuba just had this afro rhythm thing and
i'll tell you
my uncle's dark skin
and you know they didn't like
dark-skinned people in cuba and he'll
tell you now when he was seven adult a
guy made a dog piss on him
because he was darker skinned
you know i talk about racism in america
racism in cuba is horrible but
he until now we talk you know once a
week and he'll laugh he'll go i didn't
know my luck would change when that dog
would piss on me if i knew what i knew
now i would have had him piss on me even
more you know but
but it changed baseball
it changed music
it changed music and athletics yeah
athletics like the way people think like
you know i get a thing every once a year
from some jerk off that listen to a
podcast i didn't like the racism
doug there was no racism
i grew up
you know having all that around me when
you're cuban there's no racism i mean i
ain't gonna lie to you the first time i
saw my cousins i [__] ran in the room
and locked the door because
i i swear to god like my
and my mom was pissed at me for like a
week she's like that's your family i go
they can't be what am i adopted i'm the
only light-skinned [__] in that
picture it looked like a it looked like
the nets when we were kids the next i
look like one of the
water boys like i was like a bull boy
from my family everybody's dark some of
them got afros some of them got light
skin some it's [__] crazy we like
cats
you know and i think like every couple
years they spit out a white one then you
look at my cousins they're both dark
skinned i mean you look at them and they
like
so i sit here sometimes going i don't
know what the [__] happened i don't want
to know
but it made for an hour that's some
african in you oh like a [__]
no question about it
no question about it and you're lucky to
have it because i am yeah you're blessed
nothing to be ashamed of yeah blessed to
have it it's given me
a lot it's given me a lot and it's
helped me understand a lot
it's helping me understand a lot when i
did that 23andme i had a couple things
of me but you could see it there's all
the people that went through cuba yeah
chinese spain
african yeah
that's the people that went through cuba
i've studied the group the roots of that
music a lot and gone down to cuba
numerous times to hear it
at the source
and i don't know what it is about that
island i mean there's a lot of great
music that came out of the caribbean
from puerto rico and jamaica and
everywhere
but cuba
the music
from africa and from spain
came to that little island of cuba
and started across pollination and it
got mixed in with the religious
ceremonial stuff
that's some of the greatest music that's
ever been created in the world
some of the most rhythmic rhythmic music
exciting music sensual and sexual music
and also
sophisticated music as sophisticated as
european classical music particularly
when it gets put together with jazz
um
that's cuba's greatest creation if you
ask me is that music what it's done to
the world what it's given to the world
i listened to a lot of celia cruz yeah
old sally cruz let me tell you something
she's the aretha franklin oh you just
took it out of my mind like aretha
she's franklin
her own category
and uh in fact i drove by the sally cruz
gas station the other day in new jersey
they have a stop and i made my wife go
in i think it's union city where they
have a statue of they have the statue of
up there but they gave
uh celebrities six gas stations
gandolfini bon jovi
i don't know einstein and i know sally
cruz got one down there
so i went in there nothing a couple
pictures of her there's no spanish music
but she's got a song called
okay she's got it live and then studio
it sounds like something out of a
[__] james bond movie like in the 60s
i don't even and it's precision
you know what song i'm talking about
baby
yeah i know you're the start of it
it seems like it's something you'd watch
on tv in the 60s but i was like [__]
that music will take over your body yes
yes
it will possess you you know like
religious music can possess you
that music will possess you it changed
my life i i gotta say you know who else
he blew his mind who wrote about in his
autobiography marlon brando
marlon randall was blown away by
afro-cuban music and he learned to be a
pretty good amateur
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy how much history marlon
brando in fact last night at dinner at
the party
these guys were asking me about the
superman of cuba
and uh i said to them a marlon brando
would go see him at night and the
article says that marlon brando would go
with three show women showgirls and
leave with him you know yeah and uh
just [__] crazy superman does
everyone does everyone know what we're
talking about when you talk about
superman oh yeah i've talked about it a
couple of times i've spoken about the
superman of cuba's got an
18-inch dick dry like flat like
it must have been i heard a story once
robert duvall
went to cuba to visit it's in the
article and he says to the cab driver
take me to
the shanghai theater take me to see
superman superman had been dead for like
decades by then he was so disappointed
that he couldn't go see superman
it's uh cuba has so much [__] history
but this new book that you have i mean
listen your love for cuba has i've
learned a lot from your books i mean i i
didn't know all these stories existed
you know and with your stories and my
stories i'm just blown the [__] away
like i'm
cuba blows me away like it really does
as an island i can't believe i'm from
there
i can't believe the thought process of
those people sometimes
i'm really proud like
i love my mother
and i think i'm happy that she died
because my life would have been
completely different she would have made
me pay
for the united states like pay them back
my mother had plans already my mother
wanted me to be a marine my mother
wanted me to [__] fight for this
country
my mother had you know it's it's the
patriotism level of those [__]
pre-revolutionary cubans man did you see
the did i send you that video of ricky a
couple weeks ago when he got his
acceptance speech no in new york with
lucille ball like 1956
and he goes uh
when i came to this country i used to
clean
cages
and he goes
he goes here it is
from that night to this night in new
york city on this stage
winning this award lets you know that
this is the greatest country in the
world like they loved
america you know they couldn't they
loved everything about it you know and
and that makes me really proud
that cuba had some disgusting things you
know like when you read the superman of
article cuba you know americans were
getting off the plane just to shoot to
go see this guy [__] a chick yeah you
know it was really [__] filthy
well it goes way back you know the
caribbean was the crossroads of a lot of
uh
you know the pirates and all that kind
of [__] a lot of commerce illegal
commerce
selling of spices and coffee and all
that stuff
and so those those islands in the
caribbean were kind of established
as a kind of uh place to go and engage
in
illicit activities that you couldn't
engage engaging back in your home
country that was part of the
tradition and part of the appeal to lure
people from all over the world to come
to the islands you know what happens in
cuba stays in cuba that whole mentality
and so that became a legacy of the
island that cubans had to live with
for centuries after that you know the
idea that you come to this island and
abuse it and use it for your own
personal form of entertainment and then
you go back to where you came from
some of that was good some of that was
bad you know i think superman is part of
that legacy
full superman it was it was weird in
1985 i had a panamanian neighbor in
cliffside park
in fact it was my friend's grandmother
and we were talking one day and she goes
cuba's a country that's
it's cursed
god put a curse on it because of all the
bad things that were done now now
and i'm like i remember watching
homicide and that's one of the first
times i actually saw like i i heard
glimpses like i know you know santorini
i know slaves went through that but i
didn't know it was a slave
port how many of those [__] slaves
put a curse on that [__]
country like you know on the way out
they were african dads yeah but they
blessed it too man they blessed it too
they brought all that great music they
brought all that spiritual
vibrations through that island you know
it's a it's a mystical place to go and
experience the culture there and
what that what that island has
contributed to the arts in the world
arts and athletics
uh there's nothing else like it that i
can think of you know all the little
irish na uh all the little island
nations are very
proud uh i'm irish we that's an island i
think there's always a mentality of
people who come from an island country
because you're an isolated you're just
you know you don't have neighbors you're
surrounded by water and usually they're
small in comparison to the land masses
where the other countries are based
and so
you have a real sense of pride when you
come from that kind of a a place
and
when when you excel when you seek to
succeed at something when you come from
a place like that you really
do it like over the top almost like you
have something to prove you have a lot
to prove you know cubans are like that
puerto ricans are like that irish i wish
i liked that yeah it's so weird the
irish cuban
connection like i never lived through it
so i don't know what happened with the
battle of wine and how they ended up in
cuba yeah and partying in the catholic
country that's all great and dandy but
then i look at the culture and how it
affected me as a cuban right
i married an irish chick
when i was dating
white chicks whatever they would come
and go
irish chicks stayed
if you listen to my love you know 1312
mcneil
colleen maynes
you know i was a moran i was an irish
lover
and i couldn't figure out why irish
girls liked me i'm like one of these
girls even talked to me that's a [__]
lady who's a genius she's beautiful on
twitter she's a doctor
okay in milwaukee her and her father
come to my shows
i love her to death
she came to l.a and go i'll meet you at
the store i'm like this girl trust me
like jesus christ who trusts me
because they're [__] irish
and
they fathers are crazy
irish dads are [__] nuts yeah
so when they see me they're like this
guy's perfect like you know this follows
the [__] uh that's funny so i don't
know sometimes the culture father like
i'm trying to explain i'm not explaining
it right like i had a friend in college
she was korean
and i knew i was friends with her
boyfriend and one day i asked him
where's your girlfriend he goes she goes
to the hospital every other
period okay she had every other time she
had a period
she would have to check into the
hospital for five days
so one night we were then after that and
i don't like to talk about periods and
all this [__] so we were just talking
and she was explaining to us what really
happens to her and she says that she
carried
the sins of her culture
that the pain that
her grandmothers and everybody endured
like for years
dog it sounds
[__] crazy
but that's what it turned into her well
that's a big burden to have to carry man
her her mother had a period like this
you know i hope she got some good things
out of it too
you know i don't know what i'm saying it
was the look i had i faint
i faint you know and one day somebody
some guy was telling me in college
because the reason why you faint is
because you came from spanish ancestry
from spain and they were in a war and
when they were getting conquered they
faint to act like they were dead
and when you can't handle stuff you
faint
that's part of who you are as a culture
your great grandfather might have been a
[__] soldier but that stayed with you
through your genes that pain
like korea went through a war that's
what she was saying yeah that pain from
the war what happened to them she
carried that for years and it's
i don't know i don't know if it's hard
to believe but
i see it sometimes in my life
i see what the cubanism the doors that
opens for me
the things that i attract to naturally
you know my daughter's irish and [__]
cuban
she joined the school band that's a
great combination okay guess what she's
playing
the [__] drums right okay the
teachers seem to play the drums and go
sit the [__] down when we go to jimmy
florentine's house and the boys and the
girls are playing she goes in his garage
and you hear blah blah blah
see what that is is like i was married
to a brazilian
this when you when you are drawn to
cross
cultural boundaries in the friends that
you choose and and significant others
that you choose i think
in a way you're seeking to complete some
part of yourself
there's something in that other culture
that you feel that you don't have
and by forming a relationship with that
person you complete yourself
right
and some cultures are particularly well
suited together to do that i think the
irish and the cubans
have enough in common that that's what
draws them to each other and then they
have the things that are dissimilar that
help them complete themselves for
instance irish being northern europeans
can be kind of physically uptight
you hang out with a cuban woman man
you're going to get loose
you're going to get loose physically
you're going to get loose and i think
humans benefit from a little more steady
uh
i shouldn't say steady emotional but
from a little more of an intellectual
uh instinct that the irish might have
that they don't have
so they get that that's what they get in
return i'm stupid well and my wife runs
the [__] operation okay so i depend
on her
for everything but my wife you know
about the irish and the cubans have
though a [__] temper
the the temper that goes off
uh
the emotionalism the heart wearing your
heart on your sleeve
um
responding emotionally to everything you
know not all cultures understand that
uh irish and cubans have that you know
it's something that's understood between
them it's a it's a perfect combination
i don't know like whenever i go to the
doctor my blood pressure's up
but then we take a breather and then my
blood pressure drops
and for years i've had this problem but
i feel great it doesn't really affect me
and i think that my engine runs out
yeah my engine runs a little harder than
people like i'm [__] passionate about
[__] and i've gotten
like i've lightened up
because i remember being 25 and people
think joey come in
you got it you got me this is not good
yeah you're gonna blow a gasket and i
remember now you're saying that to me
one day i was working on a dealership
there was an issue about money
and without saying the word i went in
the back i got a sledgehammer and i got
on one of the cars
and i said if i can get my money i'm
gonna start breaking windshields and one
guy you know came out he's like joey
joey stop come here because what's the
problem how much he gave me the money he
goes come back monday take the weekend
off and he was an irish guy
billy sullivan was his name and i'll
never forget this guy because he was
white
he was rich he was intelligent he was
irish by name you know those people like
he was irish by name but
he read me correctly and when i came
back monday goes come here for a second
he goes bro i gotta love you
i [__] will because i [__] adore
you i've been thinking about you all
weekend he goes i don't meet people that
wear their heart on their sleeve anymore
i haven't since i left the war he goes
people are just bland
he goes i love you did that he goes in
fact i'm not even going to call you joey
i'm going to call you renegade
because he would call me renegade every
time he saw me and when i went to prison
he sent me money and he wrote me a
letter and he goes you're going to be
fine you're going to come out of your
head
standing on your feet the right way i
mean he just understood me but when he
said that to me goes come in my office
he goes you [__] cuban [__]
and he goes ah don't disrespect i don't
want you to go off he goes but the
passion the heart on the sleeve is that
that's he goes you don't see a lot of
people and i never knew what that meant
but
i love
the same like if i love you i love you
yeah yeah if i [__] hate you i
[__] hate you with everything i got
you know yeah when i want to help you
i'll do anything in the world for you
i'm one of those guys and that is a nice
cuban tradition we're very
we're very open i read an article by a
woman who's a cuban 20 years ago she was
she wrote for the chicago newspaper
and she said that she visited cuba she
had no idea about cuba and she goes
these people had nothing
but they'd always offer you a glass of
water oh you went to the house because
people in the united states don't even
think of that [__]
she goes in cuba they would ask you a
glass of water they'd give you a coffee
she said the coffee tasted terrible that
they had to use the filter like 10
[__] times
but uh it's a really weird [__]
culture to be a part of
when i was a kid i was really ashamed of
it
i didn't understand it
nobody would come to my house because of
my santoria stuff
i wouldn't allow anybody in my house not
to mention my mother was a [__] you
know i saw him being sick and her going
if you don't start wiping your ass
and you keep [__] your underwear i'm
gonna thumbtack them to the [__] door
so your friends can see it when you come
over here and one day she goes i'll
thumbtack it to the to the your bedroom
door first and it continues again i'll
thumbtack it to the front [__] door
certainly sees your stinky ass
[__]
man if they'd reported her to the child
services agency right they would have
come and taken you away from her not
even close in the 70s
that was mild yeah i knew kids well let
me ask you growing up in union city um
you say being ashamed of it um you were
surrounded by cubans right it wasn't i
was ashamed of it when i started going
to school at first i speak the language
and i you know but my mother tried very
hard to like remove the accent my mom
didn't want me to have an accent she
wanted me to be an american
so she didn't want me to sound like
ricky ricardo
so it took a couple years santoria was
very embarrassed about i didn't know
what the [__] we were doing here
it worked for me i got healthy
i wasn't gonna talk about it
but i wasn't gonna i liked when i was
with those people
and then were you raised catholic yes so
you very catholic you were baptized yes
right catholic very tight with my god so
was i my mother was the type of person
that she'd be driving in the city and
she'd see a pretty church she'd [__]
pull over
go inside and tip the [__] guy and
give him a bottle of
doors or something like that yeah i mean
i came from that foundation so
once i got to union city
i don't know i started talking to people
and i saw all these bodega owners and i
heard their stories
and
it gave me a sense of who i was but it
wasn't until 1985 when i went to san
francisco after my mother had died
that i became friends with a street gang
of mariolitos
then i realized
i was very proud for being
cuban it was those mariolitos that
instilled that right no [__] i didn't
know this because they had they were
successful people they were on the
streets selling drugs and stabbing
people
but in cuba they were engineers there
were dentists they were lawyers yeah and
when they came here all that got taken
away from them and i saw their
drive to be americans and i saw their
drive to succeed
whatever it was yeah they sold nickel
bags but a lot of them were janitors at
schools at night
they sold nickel bags to me they
couldn't speak english so i saw
i got a culture explained to me like my
mother didn't explain it to me growing
up like you took it for granted and now
i wanted to i yearn for that knowledge
like six years after my mother died and
these marialitos
broke it down for me
that's amazing because the marijuanitos
got stereotyped and badmouthed a lot by
other cubans
by other cubans they got outcasts
uh because i guess the cubans who'd been
here for a while
feared that the
the reputation of the mariolitos was
gonna bring them down so they separate
they were like we're not like the
mariolitos they they demonized the
marriage
yeah and for a reason what's the reason
and they burglarized their homes
uh let me take a short break yeah real
quick and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors what's happening
you beautiful people i'm here to talk to
you about better help you got to take
care of your mind listen we spend a lot
of time taking care of our skin our hair
our teeth
the tan but the most important part of
the body is the brain your brain health
affects
how you experience life investing time
and energy and mental health is going to
be crucial to your happiness that's why
i'm coming to you with better help
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable
i've been with better help now for about
14 months i feel a lot better i started
working with dana she gave me exercises
we talk
it's online video or phone or chat
therapy if you don't want to see nobody
they won't see you either let me tell
you something about better health it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and it works and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours you understand me joint listeners
i'm going to get you 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz call them contact them today
and you'll have a therapist within 48
hours and it's affordable you're not
going to get an in-face therapist right
now the pandemic killed her so listen to
your uncle joey
i love dana she's helped me out a lot if
you following the joint you could see
i've made some great hurdles so
joint listeners i'm going to get you 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
diaz again that's betterhelp.com
diaz
better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
diaz and now
back to my man tj so about the
mariolitos marillitos now do you did
your viewers know what the mariolitos
mariolito is uh you know the bulk of
cubans came after the revolution in 59
60 61 then cuba tightened up for a few
years and then
uh from constant pressure you know
i guess uh
i don't know some type of something
happened in cuba
here's what happened it's interesting
carter was president carter was
president and carter
said
cuba's mistreating their people and he
announced that we will take in any
cubans that want to leave cuba right
and you will be given a special
privilege and citizenship when you get
here and so castro
hearing this
uh
emptied the this is this is the legend
he emptied the mental hospitals and the
prisons
and put them all on a boat boats a
series of boats i mean we're talking
hundreds of thousands over the course of
like a week
and they all left from the town of uh
marielle which is why they were called
mariolitos and they came over here in a
flood like
hundreds of them on little boats and
everything it was really uh desperate
like a act of desperation and they came
over here and it was not easy for them
to assimilate there was it was too many
of them too fast and so they wound up
living in camps underneath the
expressway in miami and uh
and that was that and they got a really
bad reputation because the reputation
was that they were criminals and that
they were
low lifes
and um that was a whole generation of
cubans who landed here it's amazing that
you were you were getting to know them
so you were able to go below the
the stereotype you were able to actually
interrelate with them as human beings
and learn you know they reminded me of
who i was right
i was lost my mother had died in 79
on november that that influx happened
like six months after that
and i'll never forget it bothered me
because my mother was waiting for her
daughter
my mother's whole
[__] life at that time was trying to
get my sister out of cuba
and here she died so since i was alive
because i came from the states i would
hear on the phone every day with
attorneys and congress people speaking
spanish english trying to get her
daughter and then but
my sister ended up marrying a soldier
who was a kami so
by that time my mom died and then they
opened up marielle i was
when my mom died and touched cuban food
for two years you know there was no
reason to eat cuban food for two years
i was just eating italian food and i
became a criminal and i lost who the
[__] i was i was like lost
and in 84 i finally was homeless and i
went and visited my uncle
in california and he started giving me
some of my family history
telling me my mother murdered a guy that
tried to rape her sister and i was a
murderer and all and i was like [__]
so i almost killed my uncle you know i
was going to step we pulled guns on each
other
because it was too painful to comprehend
the things he was saying to me but my
family
then a year later i end up in san
francisco and one day i'm walking just
to see what's going on i'm living in the
tenderloin which is not the best [__]
part of san francisco at the time
and sure enough on the block next to uh
there was a coffee shop that was a
topless coffee shop
[Music]
you know the ugliest women ugliest tits
you ever seen in your life coffee
couldn't even save those days
i forgot what it was called
and it was down the corner there was a
pawn shop and around that corner was all
these you know i went down and i saw and
also i heard the lingo
what the [__]
what are you guys doing we're cuban oh
[__] i'm [__] cuban we started
talking
and then they told me what they did they
sold nickel bags you know they they uh
they uh
dealt with travelers checks
so i became i spoke english i was like
their leader now i had a suit and i
spoke english what year was this 85
oh [__]
so they were running that block down
there and it was
hilarious it was
i learned a lot you know i remember one
day it was the guy that you had to pay a
victor his name was el pudo
nothing went on on that block
unless it went through el puro el puro
e-l-p-u-r-o yeah which means if i want
to sell tj
an ounce of coke but mike wants to stab
him we got to go through pluto and he
gets a taste of whatever we take from
mike it's just like the mafia but it's
on a block it's in a small thing i
actually like
el pudo because he was old he was black
a dark-skinned cuban with white hair and
a white beard
and the funniest thing he said to me one
day was i was talking to him and some
mexican guy comes up to him speaking in
spanish in english excuse me
can i borrow a dollar from you and he
goes
what the [__] is wrong with you he goes
after all the kicks in the ass the
americans did to you he goes you want to
speak english to me you dumb
[__] because california belonged
to the mexicans and the white people
kicked you out of there and now you want
to speak english get the [__] out of
here speak to me in spanish you [__] and
i was like wow this guy is [__] heavy
duty you know el poodle you know what
you know what uh cubans call they don't
call cigar cigars right they call them
poodles
i wonder if that's where that comes from
yeah poodle they call them and then i
became friends of the guy bamboozy and
he was a [__]
engineer
he had gone to germany and all these
cuba had sent them there to build and
you know and now he's in [__] san
francisco selling nickel bags next to me
trying to and i would talk to them every
day and they would tell me about their
struggles how they got picked to play
baseball
uh you had to go to castro's events and
if you didn't clap eight hours on sunday
ten hours
if they missed you falling asleep forget
it if you didn't go to work you went to
jail for a year if you oh my god they
just filled me the [__] in but it gave
me that balls i needed at the time i was
still shell shocked in my mother's death
yeah and just getting that education
that little history reminded me nice oh
who the [__] i was nice because i i
lived in san francisco in like 84 into
85 yeah same time i was in i was about
time they're at i hate ashbury oh okay i
lived in the mission district okay yeah
i lived in virginian hotel
on o'leary maybe
i was it was three months i lived in san
francisco and
i apologize to san francisco every time
i fly in there it was three months of
just
you know going to japan town and [__]
cash and travis checks and
my god one of the funniest stories
though i learned that because when i was
a kid my mother always told me about
bugarrons
and she goes
wrong and i would go what the [__] are
you talking about and one day she told
me it's a guy who goes to prison that's
what they call a guy who goes to prison
[__] prisoners
but he lets them suck his dick he don't
suck dead deck he's like the man in the
relationship in a gay relationship but
he doesn't take it in the ass he just
pitches there's no catching involved
with these [__]
that's how you tell yourself you're not
gay yes no no i know this for a fact
because it's like uh there's a famous
cuban musician [__] santa maria yes and
when he came to the united states he
lived at the street level and i was told
this by a fellow musician who heard it
directly from him and he was like oh
yeah we used to go
to the meatpacking district in new york
city and i would let i would let gay
guys suck my [__] and then his friend
said i didn't know you're a [__] he said
i'm no [__] don't you dare call me a [__]
i let somebody suck i let him suck my
[__] i didn't suck his guy it's crazy
when i was a kid that [__] was being
talked around me and i'm like that don't
sound good and i remember i had like a
guy that used to go to my mother's barn
he used to go you should tell one of
your five-year-old your fifth grade
friends to suck your dick you could you
could talk them into sucking your dick
it'll be tremendous experience for you
and i'm like what are you [__] like
what are you talking about i don't want
a guy suck i don't want a girl stuck in
my dick in the fifth grade i want a guy
sucking my [__] dick in the fifth
grade
so but that was
he had two gay guys selling coke for him
on the corner and he would stay in
between the both of them they both had a
day shaving they would put a wig on
heels hot pants the blouse
pillows and the titties
and
when they would [__] up he would
backhand them
right on the street like knock him down
and stupid and he'd punch him
and they'd go down they get back up and
fix their wig and it was like nothing
happened that's some pimp [__] there
that is white pimp supremacy [__] that's
cuban but you did time right so you know
about you know about fifi
[Music]
uh some cuban friends of mine in miami
who did did some time told me get some
serious time like 20 25 years
uh eventually
they created uh
they created a vagina
they used like the roll of a used up
roll of toilet paper and then they like
dressed it up somehow
and to give it um
to give it flexibility and they called
it fifi
and it was the hottest [__] thing in
jail everybody wanted fifi and some of
the prisoners became really good at
creating the fifi
and the fifi was well you closed your
eyes and you put your dick in there and
you you thought you were you were
[__] a female
if you had a good imagination you use
your imagination
i i don't have that type of imagination
i really don't
how many years did you do one okay if
you've done ten
your imagination would have got a lot
better probably well i had a good
imagination i banged it out in the
shower every day
my floor was slippery
but i didn't need to [__] something like
the one what was years ago what did
rogan have that you [__] the glass
remember everybody bought them a million
[__] things sold
that you came in it you jerked in the
cup come on man yeah no i am i need a
cup in my house for me to come on i
don't know when that happens you got
[__]
problems man i i don't need that
you know tj it's a it's really great
that i get impressed i you're my
inspiration but
one of the things that makes me proud to
be cuban was the last couple years by
the books that you've written no
it's really filled in a lot of gaps that
i needed because i lost my mom earlier
my dad and they used to tell me all
those stories but when you're 13 you
don't give a [__]
and then after they die you go now i
give a [__] i want to hear all those
beautiful stories you know i was telling
somebody uh
the cop that i lent uh the book to about
battle
i go havana nocturne
was one of the best ten dollars i ever
spent my life
it was like ten twelve dollars on amazon
he goes i think my friend sent me a copy
and i bought a copy twelve dollars or
something
it filled in so many all these books
that i read give me pride
you know what happened joey with the
cuban experience i think um
because of the revolution
of 1959
and
cubans getting exiled out of cuba not
immigrants exiles getting forced out and
winding up in the most traumatic of
circumstances in the united states
and then the and then the hostilities
continued in some ways got even worse
between the united states and cuba after
the revolution and so a lot of uh cuban
history a lot of cuban stories got
repressed
there's so much about being cuban that
you weren't able to talk about that your
parents kept from you that your uncle
kept hidden you know at the dinner table
deep dark stories don't talk about that
i don't want to talk about that so a lot
of your generation
inherited a kind of repression about
their own history and their own culture
i'm i'm i
i meet this all the time through cuban
citizens
i get to know that that it's repressed
and so i since i've been writing these
books
that go into some hidden history some
untold history about the cuban
experience
i've had a lot of younger cubans come up
to me and say what you're saying they're
like i didn't know this this reminds me
of my uncle or my aunt or these stories
they wouldn't talk about let me tell you
this and they want to tell me their
their family stories i think i think the
entire there was an entire generation of
cuban americans that just got cut off
from from their own cultural history
and are just now starting
to experience it and learn about it and
uh
because i was worried when i did these
books number one i'm not cuban and here
i am mucking around in uh
in the in some very um
you know emotional controversial history
cuban history and i i wasn't sure how
that would be received you know
and uh it's been very emotional the way
it's been received cubans are really
touched by it like i remember when i did
event a nocturn which came out you know
like 10 years ago 11 years ago
and i i remember when i was working on
it i kept thinking you know at some
point i'm going to finish this book and
i'm going to have to go to in a room
full of cubans
to present this book
and if they don't chase me out of that
room
and they don't come after me
that means i was successful that was my
definition of what would be successful
about that book and i remember i had a
moment i went down to books and books
in coral gables in miami uh to promote
the book to do a reading do a
presentation
and i was staying at a hotel across the
street and i came a little late the
shining my shoes i wanted to look good
and i was a little late and i got over
there and uh
uh the owner of the bookstore said oh
you're a little late i said yes sorry he
said but there's a huge crowd you want
to see and he pulled back a curtain to
show me and the room was [__] full
like overflow crowd and it was all
cubans and i gasps man i lost my breath
for a minute because that was the moment
that i had been
knowing was gonna come eventually that
was the truth i was gonna have that was
it that was the reckoning and i went out
there and they were so attentive and
welcoming
and interested it didn't matter that i
wasn't cuban
i think in a way they understood
that it had to be a non-cuban that was
going to tell this story and all they
wanted was it be a non-cuban who was
honest and sincere and cared and
connected their heart with it you know
that's what mattered you know show us
the respect and we want to know and and
it was it was incredible and it was that
way with the corporation i went back to
that same
bookstore and the crowd was even bigger
man you know authors are not used to
going to events where
they have to turn people away at the
door because it's an overflow crowd the
only time i get that with these books is
when i go to miami all the cubans turn
out
they want to know they want to know this
history
i'm surprised that you
the battle book is phenomenal you know
but i'm surprised
it was received so well
i am too i always surprise me i have my
reasons and i'll tell you what well
there's some people who attacked me and
come after me you know there were i mean
you cannot write about cuban politics
and not piss somebody off right you know
there's two sides and they feel very
strongly and they do they're well past
the point of listening to each other on
this subject they just have their
beliefs and that's it and they would die
and kill for those beliefs and they have
and some of those people came after me
there was a lot of vicious stuff online
about
about it about the politics of it but
generally i think especially among
younger cubans
your age and younger
they don't want to fight that battle
anymore they don't they we've already
heard it they're overwhelming they're
over it they want to know the history
you know they want to give me an honest
truthful version of it you know they
want to know you know there's a couple
different types of cubans and i had to
find out the hard way
there's cubans like me that are
you know
it runs in our blood we would do my god
knows what man my grandfather was so
junk not heroin but he picked up junk
from the street and fixed it and sold it
and my uncle goes that's where you got
yourselves in the ship he goes you got
to see your gran whenever i have lunch
with my uncle he's like i can't believe
how much you look like my father how
much you act like him the way your
salesmanship you know and that makes me
happy all that type of [__]
i never forget
meeting a cuban guy at an audition one
day
and he goes what do you do and he was
very nice no santeria you know
and he came to my show that night and he
was great his wife was great after the
show
they ran out of that
and the next day two days later i called
him what'd you think of the show he goes
i was a little upset and i was a little
hurt and insulted
by your material and i'm like what did i
say because you just [__] on cuban
people
by your life and i was like embarrassed
i'm like what are you talking about
normal cubans don't act that way and
they don't talk that way and i was like
the cubans i grew up with you know
obviously this was a very uptight cuban
then i i went to my other cuban's
friend's house years later for christmas
and i brought patato in totico an album
of afro-cuban
guys when i tell you these people almost
jumped out of the window when i put that
music on because there are cubans that
don't want to know there was an african
in their in their system they haven't
gotten over that they haven't gotten
over yeah there's cubans that walk the
face of the earth and they'll say to you
uh that's got nothing to do with me afro
cuban yeah i'm cuban i'm from spain they
don't want to know it in their friends
and you look at them and you can see the
black nose or the black hands so you
know yeah they got the michael jackson
nose but you're like okay you know and
that's another cuban well that's the
rate that's racism that's the racist
cuban that's the ones that they don't
like the afro cuban stuff they like that
plain cuban music with the guitar which
sucks dick they think they're spanish
yeah they think they're spa right they
think they're spanish
so it's i knew when i didn't i thought
the van lock turn was for everybody but
for battle i thought they would be and
not till later on i thought about it i
got am i right at the third time i'm
like there might be a little resistance
even union city
oh yeah i remember we were going to do
an event there and he backed out at the
last minute back down yeah and then my i
knew they were going to back out i
remember when you came to me with that
and like oh they love your book in union
city
uh
we got someone that's going to put on
this public event there and i'm like
really they're going to do that in union
city i remember i said to you they're
really going to do that you're like yeah
they're going to do it i'm thinking i
don't think so
battle is a very controversial figure in
the politics in union city that's a
that's a tough line to walk you know
that's what they did and they pulled out
they didn't like a week before the event
they didn't like the they they didn't
care about the battle stuff
they didn't like the
bringing up oh yeah the old history in
union city i mean my brother who's a
ex-cop in jackson he lives in jackson
but he's the next cop in north bergen
he sent me
messages he got from union city cops
they called me a liar
huh they were like that kid's lying i'm
not lying i know what i've just just so
people will know and you probably talked
about this before but union city was one
of the centers of the anti-castro
movement in the united states and this
was an underground movement
that was uh i guess we could call in a
way kind of a terrorist movement i mean
they used terrorist tactics bombings
assassinations
all kinds of [__] it was a dirty
dirty little war
um and union city was one of the centers
of that miami and union city
but union city was more quiet because
they were looking at miami for it in
union city you could run that [__] well
i was told by people in that movement
that union city was the more militant
hardcore hardcore you know uh miami is
kind of the intellectual they formed the
organizations they raised the money but
when you wanted to carry out operations
you got the boys from union city well
looking at that book i read i never knew
that hudson county had the most car
bombs in the country yeah in 1975 and i
live in hudson county what the [__] is
that [__] so and most of that was cuban
related probably and mafia stuff
well i gotta be honest with you i still
remember you know i told the story with
rogan with you
and i stand by it about the dirty cuban
cop and yeah a lot of people got mad
about that story because yeah they made
him out to be this [__] hero and he
wasn't and uh yeah they gave him a
plaque and everything yeah and i saw
like i don't remember all the names
but my mother was friends with that
hard knock cuban
numbers bar game there was a lot of
there was a cafe
uh there was a guy named boyo trite i
forget what his that means sad [__]
that was what they called him his face
looks like a sad [__] so they call him
boyte
yeah you know there was a little and i
still remember them
in my mind i know a guy they call
bullets titty stay sad balls sad boss oh
no they got all those names for cubans
but i still remember that back room when
i walked in from school and i was making
believe i was making my soda with the
cherry in it and loading ice and i still
remember what those guys were saying and
the hatred
i still remember the hatred in their
voice
the hatred my stepfather you could not
mention this is part of the trauma this
is part of the trauma yeah you cannot
mention fidel in fact that's why my
stepfather was a [__] but i
respected his cubanism because
after marielle
he paid 30 000 to get his brothers
brought here and the third day he was
walking in union city with them and one
brother yelled at the guy in the street
you know what my stepfather did he put
him right back on the plane and sent him
thecube
his own [__] brothers
his own this is for that one word just
for that one word which is like a
communist word come on wow whatever the
[__] they say right right done done
done
talking about this beautiful [__]
book i haven't finished but what i've
read is [__] just
again
i don't know anything about this so
everything i gotta read i gotta read
like two times this book is the story of
the relationship between jazz and uh or
and organized crime starting from the
beginning of both those things basically
it's just a quirk of history that jazz
and started in new orleans in the early
part of the 20th century right around
the time the first mafia family
formulated in in the united states in
new orleans a lot of people think the
mafia started in chicago or new york or
something not started in new orleans
there was a big wave of sicilian
immigration into louisiana and new
orleans and that's where it started and
uh
the music has begun i mean i don't know
you're not are you a jazz fan at all i'm
just beat with this now
i love that music and i think you learn
a lot about the united states and race
relations and all kinds of things from
jazz jazz is kind of the window into a
lot of things about american the
american experience
and uh so i always loved the music
and i had i knew that
i knew that the sicilians were the first
to start
nightclubs they weren't called
nightclubs they were called honky tonks
or dance halls or saloons
in mostly honky tonks in in
a part of new orleans called storyville
which was a famous vice district in
in
new orleans where basically where
prostitution formalized prostitution in
the united states got started
the french brought that over
the french brought it and bordellos the
idea of finery and music played in the
in the foyer of the bordello and
you know kind of like prostitution
wasn't sleazy and in the gutter that it
had an aspect of it that was like high
society and so storyville was into that
and they had all these
fancy bordellos
and there was always a piano player
playing in the foyer of the bordello and
that's kind of where jazz started that's
one of the places that jazz started it
also came from the plantations
field songs and all that kind of stuff
it also came from mother africa
there's a place in new orleans called
congo square where every sunday all the
african musicians would gather and play
those african rhythms on the drums so
all of this was like
coming together in new orleans and
creating this incredible music that took
the world by storm
the mafia happened to be there working
on the waterfronts doing local
extortions
and one of the things they were good at
the sicilians in particular were was
entertainment clubs places where you
would come to drink and
and and be entertained and so they were
the first to combine these things
and they started
were smart enough to round up these
great african-american
jazz musicians like louis armstrong and
others who were playing on street
corners
and said come to the club and play
so this started
a relationship
that that would exist for the next 80
years you know and and all the
mafiosi and the jazz musicians who were
a part of this relationship
uh
formulated the business side of the
music and so everyone came out of that
um frank sinatra which i who i write
about a lot he's in the second half of
the book
um
you know frank was a sicilian
born into this tradition of music and
the mob i mean everyone talks about
frank and his associations with the mob
yeah but put it in context frank didn't
invent it he was and he wasn't the only
one he basically was inherited this
these relationships and and he ran with
it he in some ways went farther than
anyone else was willing to go he started
using you know the mob to
negotiate things for him and to handle
business for him and even on various
occasions would hire thugs to beat
somebody up
that that was that was frank
so what it is is basically a history of
uh
organized crime from the point of view
of the music business and jazz and all
of that
so
um as we were just saying in some ways
in fact
this
relationship between the gangsters
and the jazz musicians became the model
for
the music business in general i mean uh
rock and roll certainly rap and hip hop
um that all grows out of this you know
um so it's kind of important if you're
someone who has an interest in
organized crime and the way it plays out
in the united states this is one version
of that story
you with me you're a bad [__]
i'm just
you know i never heard this before you
know what i you know what i love so you
got a book coming out right next year
right
so now you you have a an idea of what it
takes right to put a book together get
it down on paper to finish it to get it
out
you might have a deeper appreciation
now yes of what that takes i've always
loved reading
yeah that's true
and uh it's a good it's a good uh
i always feel sad i shouldn't feel sad
that's kind of condescending but i i
i always feel bad for people who don't
read
i get so much joy and pleasure out of it
and i always have
and it's how i learn about the world i
mean i also go to places and have direct
experiences
but
there's nothing like reading man
uh
for giving you context and knowledge
about things you know
otherwise i would think you'd just be a
top spinning top all the time not able
to make sense of things
reading gives you a a way of making
sense of things you know
you know for like a year i went away
from reading books just i had anxiety
and i couldn't focus yeah
and i was just reading like articles on
how to get better you know how to get
healthy and [__] like that
but over the last two months i've
started reading again it helps my stand
up
helps my focus
reading just settles me so much you know
so nothing better for me than smoking a
[__] joint
and getting into a good book when the
reef is hitting and that book is hidden
guys they not much better than that [__]
see i could tell i could tell you a
reader
when we first met
tell people how we first met joey
reached out to me after
uh the corporation came out or i think
it hadn't even come out no i hadn't even
come out yet and you heard that this guy
was right in this book i was like what
the [__] and i don't know how you got a
hold of me okay so you emailed me first
and then and then we talked
and uh
i got to admit i'm embarrassed to say i
didn't know i didn't know who you were
you know i i i grew up in the era of of
uh
of uh
george carl and richard pryor and that
was it to me that was it that was such a
high standard that was it to me that i
didn't pay attention to comedy anymore
after that me neither for a long time
and in the 80s remember in the 80s there
was like a flood of really mediocre
comedy everywhere so i had tuned it out
more or less so i didn't know who joey
diaz was
and i got up to speed a little bit and
then you invited me to a show at the
club on 23rd street oh yeah yeah yeah
and so
i came to your show and you did a set
and it was long said it was at least an
hour probably more and
you know i knew you were going to be
funny because we'd spoke and i thought
this guy's just funny being who he is
you know just
and so i thought it was going to be just
you being who you are
but the act
was very well crafted at that time yes
not now
it was very well crafted
you told the story your life basically
for an hour and 15 minutes or whatever
there was a lot of very personal stuff
in it um
i remember thinking this guy is a
storyteller that's what he is he's a
storyteller and i do think that
appreciation of storytelling is part of
what comes from reading
it's one of the things that comes from
reading how do you structure something
how do you construct it you know how do
you tell a story some of that comes from
the street corner and it's just natural
and you have that instinct or you don't
but if you're going to get up on stage
for an hour and 15 minutes
you got to put some thought into how to
structure it you can't wing it you can't
just wing it you know so i knew you had
those skills and i knew those skills had
to have come from somewhere other than
just telling stories on the street
corner i've always loved reading no i've
loved reading and i love the connection
in the chapters
and right now i'm doing stand-up and
there's a couple funny jokes in there
but doesn't connect
i'm not connecting the jokes yet in time
yeah i'll find the connection you know
you find it
but
uh there's so i remember afterwards i
said to you i said i was really
impressed with the
with the act and how well put together
it was and how well shaped it is and you
said you know i've been doing this act
for about
15 years now
and i've been shaping that same act for
like 15 years
uh that's how long it takes you know to
get it to be that good
right
it takes a while and a lot of trial and
error
um not as much trial error as writing a
book yeah that was [__] real that was
that writing a book for me was something
and i had a lot of things going on so i
like to give it another shot yeah with
something else something i know about i
like to give it another shot in time
when i have more time and i'm more
focused that helped that and that was
that book i did was during the pandemic
yeah there was nowhere i could go
i had anxiety my knee had just gotten
surgerized
so i would [__] uh
outline at night outline it to the
littlest dimension and then
we'd speak the next morning and we'd
cover a chapter and you know it was
it was rough yeah when i did it by
myself though it was rougher i i i
remember when you were doing that and it
you it defeated you kind of right oh
yeah because
listen it's something that anybody could
get a book deal this is what killed me
guys i'm gonna tell you the truth okay
i don't want to be an [__] here
anybody could get a book deal but what's
the sense of getting that deal
if i'm just going to tell a couple
stories and some guy's going to write
the book for me
i'm going to pay you 10 000 as a ghost
rider or whatever you want i don't know
what they pay i don't know what to go in
prices but i'm just saying for me
i wanted to be a part of it i didn't
want any mistakes in there i didn't want
any
i i wanted the reader
to just
i wanted him to feel what i felt at the
time
this has been very important for me with
this book because
right now i'm going through legal and
they want you to take some stories out
blah blah blah and that's fine but
i wanted the reader to really see what a
[__] mess i was
i want the guy that's reading this not
to focus on my stand-up
not to say anything about my stand-up
whether he's funny i want you to focus
on the prison the losing of the child
the losing of the parents the losing of
the father and not only that
now let's add the kidnappings
the [__] i put myself through being
homeless i did all this on my own
society didn't do [__] to me you know
but i wanted people to
see where i was in that point in my life
because there's a lot of people walking
around today that are at that point in
their life and they don't know how to
get out of that
and that's all i want to tell the reader
at home
that you don't have to stay in that
point in your life i know this is your
situation today but i'll tell you if you
want to get out of this situation i got
the answer for you in fact i don't have
the answer for you
you have the [__] answer for me
so i wanted them to understand that
there was robberies i wanted them to
know how low i got
as a human being
to show them how high i really got
that
a lot of people don't want to show you
that they just want to tell you you know
i hung out with joe rogan i'm in a limo
it wasn't that before that there was
this and it was [__] real and it hurt
and i figured out a way on how to get
out of that and it was you know it
wasn't easy i mean i i didn't stop
snorting cocktail 44 15 years ago i'm 59
years old i'm not proud of that
but that's who i was but this is who i
am now and it was a [__]
journey and a half and guess what i'd
[__] do it again
and i'd [__] do it my way again and
that's it
my way
my way back to frank sinatra back to
frank sinatra you know if the books are
hit and i think it will be uh
that's the reason they'll be a hit
because of your honesty you're honest
with yourself you're not hiding anything
[__] i'm not allowed people i was in a
helicopter with bill burr that's great
but let me tell you where i really was
dirty [__] years ago
most people hide [__] they're not honest
about it and that must be painful when
it comes time to write a book if you're
someone who's in denial about [__] and
all of a sudden you got to put it down
on the page because the page will expose
you and your your efforts to like put it
down on the page will expose you man
it's like if you're not being honest if
you're holding back
it ain't gonna work i want people to
read this book not even i don't want
people to read that like i'm not saying
it wrong but i want
what's happened in this country the last
seven years that i really do not [__]
like
i'm not talking about cancer culture i'm
not talking about any of that [__]
what bothers me the most about today is
when
some guy says that some woman says that
23 years ago the supreme court judge
covered her mouth when they were
sleeping okay he was in a [__]
fraternity or whatever and he [__] up
did he rape you no they put his dick in
your face no
so why did you release this
what was the point of you saying that
the supreme court supreme court justice
did this to you okay you understand me
now let's say he finger banged you
okay when you were sleeping
he's that's not a right for getting
canceled i can't cancel somebody for
that i can't look somebody in the eye
because they made a mistake and this is
where they are now
so that mistake is null and void because
this [__] cleans all that i'm telling
you we cannot keep doing this as
americans of discounting people the
journey that they made because when you
know i just saw somebody
[__] right about marky wahlberg that
when he was 13 he hit some guy in the
eye and the guy lost his eye and he did
his time he paid the [__] fine and
this is who he is today and you're still
going there
now does that make him a better person
than he did 40 movies
no but he's not taking people's eyes out
no more right
in fact he's inspiring
like the judge inspired me
you know people inspire me so now you
can't go chopping people for who they
were 20 years ago you know i think this
cancel culture thing is a phase and it's
going to pass but i'll tell you
something that isn't going to pass and
there's also just a bigger problem in
our
society and that is
uh how everyone's in their own
ideological camp now
like people are on the right and people
are on the left don't interact anymore
they have their own they have their own
information sources they have their own
heroes they
they demonize they demonize the other
side and that's it and i don't know how
we're going to get out of this i mean we
grew up at a time where i grew up in a
big family family of ten right nine
brothers and sisters
a lot of them had different political
points of view right there in the house
in fact my mother was a democrat and a
liberal and my father was a republican
and a conservative i'm used to the idea
of having different points of view that
i might not even agree with in your
circle and that's fine that's not
ultimately how i
uh choose a friend or judge somebody
based on their politics that's not the
number one thing with me but now that's
the number one thing with everybody
um
and if you're on the other side
they're not even going to listen to you
because they feel i don't have to i got
my i got fox news
i got msnbc i got a source that's going
to pat me on the back and feed me and
make me feel good about
my point of view they're not going to
educate me about another point of view
or someone else's point of view i don't
know how we get out of this
this is just getting more and more and
more divided
and if someone comes along like trump
who is like you know throwing a smoke
bomb in the middle of it all someone
who's that extreme in their positions
well we see what happened the whole
[__] country almost broke down
had a had a collective nervous breakdown
during those four years he was in office
right i saw a lot of people losing
everyone lost their [__] people [__]
still losing it man yeah people still
lose their [__] over it and i'm like
whoa okay
so you lose your [__] and you and your
only way of dealing with it is to
go to all the other people who think the
same way you do
and you all sit around in like a circle
jerk and and
and reaffirm each other's
uh biases and positions and [__] i don't
know how we get out of this
i don't know who breaks that down you oh
you got to write a book another [__]
book
i stay out of i stay out of politics for
the most part
i'm a felon that's mine i'm going to the
right and i'm not on the left i'm right
in the middle yeah look at my balls they
almost hit the [__] floor and that's
my political i don't want to i don't
want to look at you that's number one
the party is a simple request i don't
want to look at your balls the party i
belong to is the felony party okay you
don't want to talk i have politics i
just it's not the thing i lead with it's
not no you know what i mean no but over
the last six or seven years
america a lot of people that i knew that
were just regular people also the
political [__] experts and
you know what if you don't even know
about hudson county how you gonna be a
[__] political aspect last night i
was watching someone 12 news
uh the jersey city democrat she ran the
light and [__] jersey politics oh my
god the best and some guy came here it's
like mud wrestling oh my god she was she
was getting her car towed because she
double parked so she called
like the hoboken police and said that
you can't do this i'm a committee woman
but the line of the night was when they
called some other guy and they asked him
they go what do you think is going on
here listen this is all a part of the
hudson county machine
yeah
they're not gonna do nothing she's a
congresswoman what is she a committee
woman but she lives in [__] no man
housing
she lives in like under 800 000 8 000 a
year housing so that's jersey pilot you
know so everybody wants to know about
politics if you don't know about [__]
hudson county and if you don't know
about cook county don't even let's start
then and like i tell people i grew up in
hudson county and that was the
micro
i got to see the micro of corruption i
can't picture
what the macro of corruption is the name
frank hague mean anything to you [__]
yeah
[__] yeah
they built the hospital by his wife
margaret he was an irishman
uh
this country the the urban areas were
founded by political machines that
mostly were led by irish politicians
see the irish had one advantage of
amongst the ethnic groups they the
immigrant groups they spoke english
they spoke english which was a
tremendous advantage and so a lot of the
other immigrant groups
gave a certain amount of power to the
irish politicians they're like they're
immigrants like us buddy speaks english
and uh the irish had a certain talent
for that political leadership you know
and so you had these political machines
in places like here
in jersey
um
of course boston had one [__] kansas
city missouri the pendergast machine
controlled the whole town
and there was always this jovial
although frank hague wasn't jovial he
was kind of an uptight guy but he ran
this [__] area he was the political
boss of the local machine he wasn't the
elected official he was the man behind
the man he was the guy
that put all the pieces together he
chose
for office right he chose who was going
to get elected
he chose who was going to be the police
commissioner in a certain area he chose
who was going to be in the positions of
power that's how powerful he was he was
the man behind the man frank hague i
always wonder about guys like that
because in his day he was the most
famous and powerful person in this area
you've said that you see the name frank
hague at the dinner table and everyone
would [__] bow and say a prayer
now the name means nothing i mean it's
on a few buildings somewhere but nobody
remembers is that with the guy from
boardwalk empire also probably yeah yeah
they brought him in yeah that's right
they brought him yeah he was in there
because i know margaret haye and that
was his wife who they named the hospital
no kidding and jersey city the hospital
got torn down real quick i just want to
leave you with one thing i know you know
this story
ricky ricardo friends with [__] al
capone oh yeah yeah i mean uh this pool
got him the job in the club right this
book um dangerous rhythms deals with
this overlapping capone was a huge jazz
fan yeah he loved it he also loved opera
opera was his italian side and jazz was
his american side and he was a patron of
the clubs and he owned four or five
clubs in and around chicago owned a
piece of them one that's still there
called green mill a club in chicago
that's been there since 1908 if you're
ever in chicago uptown chicago great
little club
kind of like chicago's version of the
village vanguard here in in new york the
cup these are a couple of the oldest
clubs in america um
he uh he loved it in fact he loved it so
much
he once
heard um he went to a club and he heard
for the first time fats waller
i don't know if this name means anything
to anybody but i urge you go online and
look up some clips of fat's waller
that's waller was a jazz entertainer
in uh
the 20s 30s and 40s he wrote the song
this joyous jump in he wrote honeysuckle
rose some songs that are legendary
and he was a fantastic entertainer he
was
drunk and high most the time and he
would do facial expressions twitching
eyebrow he was just a very entertaining
guy to watch he would fall in love with
this guy when you saw him perform and he
was in some movies so if you look at
clips on youtube you will have
opportunity to see him in all his glory
capone saw him one night that this guy's
the greatest [__] guy he left there
like oh what a great
jazz musician so a couple of the next
night a couple of capone's underlings
come to the club
and at gunpoint
they go to fats waller after a set and
he says
you're coming with us and he's like what
what what you're coming with us here's
what we're going to do we're going to
take you to a hotel in cicero suburb of
chicago
which was kind of capone's base of
operations we're going to put you up at
a hotel there and over the weekend
you're going to perform
at al's birthday party and it's going to
be a surprise he doesn't know you're
coming and he's going to love it
and so they take him at gunpoint he's
[__] scared to death the kid they
kidnapped him basically they kidnapped
him they take him to this hotel
he's brought in to perform at the
birthday party capone loves it he's
[__] overjoyed that's all they're
here this is great
he performs for like two and a half days
they [__] bury him in cash they
lavish him in cash
uh fast waller leaves chicago he says he
had like three thousand dollars on him
which is probably thirty thousand or
more today and he had a great story to
tell for the rest of his life about how
he was kidnapped about al capone to play
at his birthday party
i love all those [__] stories man and
then there's another one in chicago this
is
a lot more violent i mean the fats
waller one is kind of a funny story this
was a guy named joey lewis joe e lewis
white guy
he was a type of entertainer that came
out of the vaudeville days he would sing
songs and tell jokes
and he was hugely popular and he was
playing at green mill which was co-owned
by capone and other mobsters and he was
a hit
he filled the place every night in fact
he was so popular that another club in
town
said when your contract is up
whatever they're paying you will double
it come with us
and so joey lewis goes to the owners of
the club and he says i'm mike the
contract's up i'm leaving i'm going to
go play at this other place and they
said no you're not
and he said yeah my contract's up you
know you can't hold me i'm going the
other place they said no you're not
don't do that you're not going to do
that
we'll we'll give you the money but
you're not leaving and going to another
club he said yes i am and he did he left
he went to another club
uh he played there for a few nights
and then some goons came to his hotel
room about four o'clock in the morning
with knives and blades and [__] slit
his throat stabbed him multiple times
[__] brutal attack i mean i think
they were trying to kill him
but he survived it no he never he never
sang again because his his vocal cords
never fully recovered
but he
became an entertainer and a pretty
famous entertainer in fact he wrote a
memoir about what happened to him called
the joker's wild it was made into a
movie frank sinatra played him wow in
the movie joey lewis joey lewis
but that story became a cautionary tale
that scared the [__] out of
jazz musicians for decades to come
that's what could happen if you said no
to the mob guys who owned the club you
know that was the worst case scenario
they could [__] come and kill you
attempt to kill you and you know here's
here's what's even funnier about that
one of the hoodlums that came and slit
his throat was a young was a young
19 year old chicago gangster named sam
giancana
who would go on to be you know anyone
who knows the history of the mob knows
that gian connor was
became the boss of chicago and
also became a very close friend and
business partner of frank sinatra
so i always wondered about that i
mentioned it in the book it's like
here's frank sinatra
playing joey lewis who was attacked by
giancana
and now he becomes good friends and
partners with giancana
what the [__] is that i mean how do you
become
best friends with one guy and best
friends with another guy who attacked
that guy and tried to kill him
how do you do that it's [__] crazy
bro you're a genius
and i love you i love you too came down
here
when does the book get released the book
was released this week all right so it's
out there dangerous [__]
rhythms
tj english does it again
brother it's so good to see you man it's
been a while it's good to be out here
let me say something about joey diaz
people may or may not know all right
joey diaz you may know wears his heart
on his sleeve
what you see is what you get
uh
he's a great friend to have he's the
kind of friend that
stays in touch even if you're like in
different states you're not able to see
each other he'll call and check in on
you how you doing what's going on
and all that and i treasure it man i
really do
we become good friends really good
friends i learn a lot from you and i
think you learn a lot from me i love you
man yeah it's the irish cuban connection
it's the irish cuban connection that's
another thing i wanted to say before we
get on
all this stuff's coming into my head now
uh we were talking about this before
um
i come from irish roots uh i i'm very
proud of it i i start an organization
called irish american writers and
artists i love hanging out with other
irish people
but for me man the great thing about the
united states of america
is crossing and connecting with people
from other cultures man i love it it's
beautiful having cuban friends having
mexican friends having black friends
crossing over into these different
cultures
learning about their culture sharing
your culture with them
this is this is america to me this is
the thing i'm most proud of
we need more americans like dj english
suckers [__]
i love you guys thank you for visiting
don't forget to check out dangerous
rhythms and uh
i don't know what to tell you have a
great [__] week i want to thank tj
english everybody and uh now for a word
from our sponsors stay black
all right you bad [__] i want
to have i want to thank you for
coming on today tj was great i love it
don't forget to look for his book
dangerous rhythms it's out
and he's a new york times bestseller but
hey
i'm coming to you now for a word for my
sponsors and that's better help like i
told you in the mid row you got to take
care of your mind guys it's all you got
and it controls you your brain affects
how you experience life
so investing time and energy and mental
health is going to be crucial to your
happiness eating right working out
getting plenty of street leap they're
all good but they're no substitute for
talk therapy better help makes online
therapy accessible convenient and
affordable listen why is therapy
important
because we got bogged down from time to
time and we need to talk to somebody and
better help has online therapy that
offers video phone and chat therapy you
could choose not to see anyone at all
you could talk to your therapist loreck
like i do with dana it's much more
affordable than in person therapy and
you could be matched with a therapist
within 48 hours listen i'm going to get
your 10 percent off your first month
at betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz the joint is also brought to you by
true classic the absolute best fitting
t-shirts for men comfortable and they're
light and like i told you if you're a
fat [__] like me it's always frustrating
to get a shirt that fits your tits pop
out the t-shirts are too tight your gut
who the [__] knows listen start dressing
like a gentleman and feel like a
gentleman with true classic they're
giving joint listeners a hookup go to
trueclassic.com
with code joey these shirts are soft and
smooth
and they they stretch this small thing
smooth are usually expensive the first
thing you'll notice
polos and workout shirts with the same
flattering fit all of their gear is
top-notch quality at reasonable prices
and for all you big boys they got long
body options and sizes up to 3l
it's time you learn how to dress like a
savage
upgrade your wardrobe to true classic
i'm going to get you 25 off
at trueclassic.com with code joey that's
25 off and free shipping if you go over
100 with co joey trueclassic.com
get yourself looking like a [__]
doctor with true classic i want to thank
better help and i want to thank true
classic but most importantly i want to
thank you savages on a monday morning
we'll be back wednesday the 10th tip top
[__] magoo ready to stab a
[__] have a great day stay black
and i'll see you guys then
[Music]
you